Hello Vsauce. Michael here,
and I've got a dozen DONGs for you today.
These are things you can do online now,
guys. In the
"I of It" you play not as a super action
hero, but rather
as the actual letter 'I.'
You elongate and
shrink yourself to grab onto ledges and
awkwardly locomote. If you want more
letters,
upgrade your life to the Roman numeral
calculator. For instance,
191 times
7 is 1337. If you brain isn't
challenged, take these quizzes
suggested by "MadebyNotch."
You listen to classic songs from
NES or SNES games and with the help of
hints prove your worth
by identifying them. If tragedy is more
your style, go with "Zombies Took My
Daughter,"
an emotional action game where you have very
little time to find your lost kin
and plenty of zombies to hide from or blow-up.
Too many graphics?
Go textile
with "EauDeParkour's" 'YouFindYourselfInARoom.' Here
you have to type your next move.
What's neat is that the computer receiving your
inputs eventually gets frustrated with you
and things get pretty twisted.
Twist around shapes with Jasmine's mind warping
suggestion.
You use six different keys to rotate
pieces to fit snugly
in all kinds of new ways.
And if you're forever alone,
enjoy the company of Myself, where you solve
puzzles by doing one thing
and then restarting, using the ghost of your
former attempt as a tool.
Now as a bonus, yourself and your ghosts
have different abilities
and it gets pretty satisfying. If you
still don't know how to upside down text,
do like "Nix4222"
and get to ToolsGeek. They'll flip text
that you can copy and paste
anywhere. I've seen a lot of creative
uses of annotation,
but "wtfdany" made one where you can beat him
up.
Just click and boom! Instant results.
Do you like a YouTube video and wish
you could loop it?
Well, "Griever179" showed me that you
can delete 'tube,'
replace it with 'repeat' and be sent to
a site that plays the video
over and over and over again forever.
Control YouTube even more
with the Video Time Machine.
This site's curatorss
verify dates and organize videos. So, say
if I wanted to watch television and
commercials from
the year I was born.
Ta-da! A huge list of
awesomeness to scroll through and
nostalgia about. For 99 cents you can get
the whole time machine as an app on your
iPhone, so it never leaves your side.
I leave you with flip books. 'BloodyRenegadeX' makes stories that will blow
your snot off.
But more personally, Frenzy Woods made a
super cool flip book
of the Vsauce outro. Check his work out,
he sent a lot of great ones.
And hey, what a perfect way to end my
reminder that...
As always,
thanks for watching.